Welcome To The Kingdom
[Music]
hey I am here with the amazing cast and
director of Marvel Studios Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania hi everyone
now we know there are some pretty
incredible things in this film what
should audiences expect when they go
into the theater there are uh a lot of
really cool visual effects in this movie
and I think you can see by the trailer
check this out you see this uh
quantumania over my shoulder
look at that if this is blowing your
mind which I'm sure it is just wait do
you see Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
it's this kind of stuff
times five I'm a little biased but I
would say I'm most excited for them to
see Mr K what is most surprising and
stunning about this film is the visuals
they are the Landscapes this Quantum
world that has been created it's so
beautiful it's so surprisingly elegant
it was really fulfilling for me this
being my third Ant-Man movie in Quantum
Mania to progress that family story
because family's always been at the
center of the Ant-Man movies and one of
the things we really wanted to explore
is the theme in this movie was the
secrets that family members keep from
one another the things that they don't
tell each other emotionally it's the
family tie how the whole Pim families
come together supporting each other I
dreamed of being a Marvel superhero and
this is better than my dreams the cast
is amazing Paul Rudd is hilarious and my
character Cassie Lang the greatest we
know our heroes are entering the quantum
realm in this film Peyton what would you
say is the most exciting part of the
quantum realm I'm really partial in the
quantum realm to the uh Quantum jungle
that hope and Hank and Janet first land
in and that was one of the great joys
for me on the movie is shepherding all
these crazy concept artists and visual
artists to come to it with their most
whacked out ideas
so for all of you who have spent time in
the quantum realm what would you say are
the most essential things that you need
to do to survive tiptoe stay very very
very quiet I would say bring a sweater
and a napkin because you know there's
some stuff that happens and you're gonna
need one well you first have to make
sure you have stuff to drink rule number
one would be stay clear of Kang the
Conqueror bring a taser growing and
shrinking tabs some snacks you can eat
some type of cloak because you don't
want to be caught in the streets of the
quantum realm and bring Janet Van Dyne
ooh it sounds like things are pretty
treacherous down there now I want to
give audiences a little peek into what's
going to happen in this movie but we
don't want to give it all away right so
could you give them a small ant or wasp
sized hint so you want some ant-sized
hints
things get very Quantum this film is
epic
I love ants there is an actor in this
movie Marvel fans might know him he was
in the first two Ant-Man movies it's
somebody you've never heard of ever oh
well it looks like we'll just have to
wait and see well thank you so much to
Peyton and the cast and for all the fans
out there go experience Marvel Studios
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania in
theaters now
[Music]